sans aucun
effort et l'appareil B l'accessibilité
pour tous attrape axol importe et
distribue des solutions techniques pour
les personnes à mobilité réduite
dispositif d'accès pour les piscines
plateformes élévatrice ou chaise
d'évacuation de quoi rendre la société
plus inclusive en raison de son histoire
personnelle Jean-Paul Mignard fonde
l'entreprise en 2010 il se trouve qu'à
l'âge de 55 ans mon grand-père est
devenu euh émip plégique suite à un AVC
euh j'avais 6 ans à l'époque et ben j'ai
vécu toute ma
jeunesse observer que pour ma famille
c'était extrêmement compliqué de lui
faire participer à toutes les activités
familiales pendant une vingtaine
d'années où il fallait le le porter en
permanence il voulait pas quitter sa
maison dans qu'il avait construit dans
lequel il a il avait toujours
vécu suite à la séation d'activité d'un
fournisseur anglais Jean-Paul Mignard a
relocalisé une partie de la fabrication
de ses produits depuis 2000 cette rampe
d'accès en fibre de verre est conçu à
trrappe d'un coup d'environ 700 € elle
permet notamment à un fauteuil roulant
d'accéder à un balcon ou une terrasse
cette rample a la particularité de
pouvoir se se rabattre voilà ça permet
le le franchissement d'un obstacle qui
est tout simplement une baie vitrée et
ça permettra à la personne de refermer
sa sa fenêtre en laissant le matériel en
place quoi un manque d'accessibilité
dans de nombreux déplacements en France
seule la moitié des structures
recevantes du public reste praticable
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite
autant des des des des gros
établissement type des banques des
grandes chaînes de magasins et cetera
sont accessibles par contre tout ce qui
est petit commerce tout ce qui est
petite communes et cetera ont pris
beaucoup de retard pour diverses raisons
pour des problèmes de coût ben aussi
quelquefois de simplement de bonne
volonté des exploitants qui on entend
encore certains qui disent ben pourquoi
j'ai m'équiper alors que je reçois
personne en situation dehicap chez moi
plus de 5000 produits ont été vendus par
la société Axel en 2023 pour donner
davantage d'autonomie l'entreprise teste
actuellement des prototypes contrôle des
rampes via le panneau de commande du
fauteuil ou un smartphone une
commercialisation espérée dans les
prochaines années pour rendre notre pays
plus
inclusif